all right Isaac yes Isaac where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
originally uh well uh Hemet California
um
yeah they're from age seven to about
well 14 when my mom gave me up I went to
a boys home
um
the boys almost at Optimist right here
up on North Figueroa
um spent most pretty much the rest of my
youth there
where did your mom give you up
why
um well
uh they they found one of my needles one
day um I started I started slamming at a
pretty young age I started something
about 14. you know so
you could I mean I don't know if you're
a father but I mean
I guess any any any parent would be
disappointed in the kids if they were to
stumbled across their their needles or
something from
from Ivy drug use you know
um it was already Rocky at the time so
that was just kind of like the the icing
on the cake or the cherry on top you
know who introduced you to drugs
um
you know what initially the first time I
got high I smoked some weed with my
cousin my other cousin Lydia
um like the turtle light so
it's kind of like um I was trying to fit
in you know I wasn't ready to be myself
um
I I continued my drug use
I started selling weed in school and I
got constantly reading School in eighth
grade I got expelled for that
um
once that happened it was just pretty
much just all downhill from that point
on you know beginning at the end I guess
you could say well at least that's what
I like to call it um
I got introduced to
uh worst drugs
um that's what I started uh messing
around with a crystal
um I started off snorting it
didn't last along within six months I
was already slamming it
um
Who Are You Raised by if your mom gave
you up uh well a bunch of stuff
so my mom I mean she was about until I
was about 14.
um
initially I wasn't supposed to stay at
the boys home I was only there supposed
to be there for six to nine months
and when I was about six months into the
program my mom just
uh told them that I wasn't coming back
home I wasn't gonna be allowed to come
back home and
um
we had a couple conversations where
she really worded with how she felt
about me and um
it was just that's where relationship
was just cut off um
I didn't want to keep bothering her
I noticed that um
she wasn't too fond of me anymore not
only that she was just she would blame
out you know I mean just
straight up tell me that
um
uh she didn't feel this anymore towards
me
that she didn't love me no more
um and that she wasn't gonna put up with
me no more so
I mean after hearing that from from one
of your from one of your parents you
know I just I mean
you kind of get you kind of get the hit
what was your childhood like before
before that happened
um
it was all right I mean it wasn't the
my mom was there my stepdad was was
there too um
he was really beautiful me
I noticed that at a really young age
I kind of understood it was [__] me you
know um I wanted a bike I had to wait
till my birthday or Christmas
uh
and my sister's wanted something they
would get it right away
you know and if I got a bike they got a
bike even though if it wasn't their
birthday or Christmas
whatever I got they got but whatever I
wanted I had to work for it
which I get is a good concept to teach
your kids but
not to the point where
you make your kids
feel a little bit less wanted than the
others
um my stepdad never abused my sisters
I can remember a couple times where I
would get hit for them
um
and it wasn't just on the regular [__]
on the butt I'm talking about like
we would have to you know turn back
around uh
on a way on our way to dinner because
I'd be covered in blood you know um
I had bust my lip open he bust my nose
open um
and I would just be being profusely and
I can't remember a lot of times being
told that it was my fault that we were
gonna be able to go out to dinner you
know
um
so that that always kind of suck in my
head
um
even to this day like my stepdad had me
so psychologically be already just
I'm still afraid of him you know I'm
still
I'm still just
there's no question again there's no you
know all day now I'm 28.
you joined the gang at some point excuse
me you joined the gang yeah I'm from
Avenues
what age were you when that started 18.
I started pretty late
um I just
I always wanted to belong to something
you know
uh uh at the time I told everybody I
didn't have a family
um
it was just me on my own
so
everybody wants to belong to something
you know whether they want to admit it
or not whether they want to you know
accept the fact that
they suffer being alone less up to them
you know
and even though you might not want to
say it like
you know at the end of the day I believe
that it's your soul that has to pay for
it you know
I really want to look at it your Soul's
the one that suffers the most
so um
yeah I I was real fond of the whole
concept that
you know everybody had their bags
everybody had each other's back
but
all along it was just like a a facade it
was just um unreal you know
and nobody gets to really see the real
picture until they're actually in it
that's when you realize that
the last 10 of your homeboys had been
killed all by your own homeboys you know
how
you don't even know it
your whole year is everybody there
everybody else there is aware of it
except for you and your best friend's
about to just shoot you in the back of
the head you know everybody's having a
party having a good time
little do you know
you're just you know you're the
guy with the cross behind his back you
know
um I feel like you're lucky to be here
today
oh yeah
yeah
um I should have done it a long time ago
there's been plenty of times multiple
various times
where I just you know I've had slug
holes
all I've been down my shirt
uh sometimes I kind of I wonder what it
is that's keeping me around I mean of
course it's got to be God
you know
that guy uh
so my religion we believe that on
everybody has a purpose in life
and it is that until you fulfill that
purpose that if you pass away you know
that's why
kids die from sins you know that's why
people just have mysterious deaths or
just people die from everything you
can't question death
this question of God God is all perfect
God is Almighty
everything is all perfection
you know and everything is all good
everything's like a good dog good God
does is all good
and that's one thing I've had a really
try to hold on to
from other misfortunes I've had in my
life
there's plenty of times where I want to
question God but I can't
you know
so
that's not having faith in him
you're doing prison time
yeah I did a little bit over two years
actually um
I got lucky uh about five days before
trial
uh they couldn't find any of my
Witnesses anymore so
they had to shoot me a low deal
I took a plea deal for from two attempt
the murders to
uh shooting Guitar by motor vehicle and
a gun enhancement
I got two years of the strike you know
you're very lucky yeah and it's crazy
because I was just about to go that day
out day that I got
I was gonna go outside for 17 years
you know I was already ready had already
made up my mind
after talking to my parents
you know they they pretty much told me
like what are you expecting you expected
to go home today and it's not gonna
happen you know
you think you could just go out and do
whatever you want and not have any
consequences to pay
because it's the truth you know people
really do like they really sit there and
expect to go home the very next day
after just
doing all kinds of chaos and just when
are you crazy who knows the world
doesn't work that way
you know do you regret joining the game
yeah
um
yeah that's the main reason why I lost
my daughters
your gutters yeah I have two daughters I
have a two-year-old and uh well
I want to know that a two-year-old
I lost it to their mom uh
I was calling gcfs owner I was reporting
her to DCFS and
everything's just backfired of me
it was all during the time where I don't
know if you remember but all those moms
are killing all their kids stabbing them
to death
there was a case with that uh mama
lisalay where she killed all three of
her kids after they took it all the kids
away from their dad saying that he was
crazy that he wasn't you know he was
reporting the mob
and a couple days later boom the mom
kills all the kids
um
yeah
I went through a lot with my daughters
um
though they were my first loves
uh
and everything was just because of the
fact that I didn't want to be with my
baby's mom no more
I don't like the way she treated them
she was real thousand
you know
and I came reporting her and every time
I reported her
it just backfired on me
you know the first time I reported her I
told him I wanted to remain anonymous
due to the fact that my life's in danger
you know her dad's from my hood or her
uncle's up for my hood
all her family's from my hood
you know they see it as I snitch it you
know that's a big No-No but at the same
time I couldn't just sit there watch my
daughters almost be killed you know
uh I caught her putting pills in my
daughter's food one day
this is during the time that my daughter
was only up for about four hours of
doing what huh you caught her doing what
what he posted my daughter's food pills
and your daughter's [__] yeah we were
FaceTiming in
I don't think she was aware of the fact
that I could see everything she was
doing with her hands at the bottom
and
right away I kind of I figured out what
she was doing I started calling her out
of her name like what are you doing you
stupid [__] pretty what the [__] you
doing
I'm watching her if this is after I had
already told her to go cook a meal for
my oldest daughter because she was about
a year and a half maybe at the time
she's not supposed to be any Gerber
Puffs anymore
that's for my youngest daughter who was
only about nine months you know
my oldest daughter she's beating a full
Girl full of full man I used to feed my
oldest daughter eight times a day and
that's not including her bottles
you know Mozart was a big fat girl
she started to be real skinny though but
I'm watching her I'm watching her take
the pill out
I watch her mash the pillar to the pill
to the food
and then throw the little Gerber puffs
into the onto the table when my
daughter's reaching and grab some
so during that time my daughter was only
up from about 10 to 12. and back to
sleep till about seven or eight you know
to be up for another two hours to go
back to sleep which didn't make no sense
you know the parents of other kids
I know my oldest daughter I don't know
her sleeping habits
she's one of those that refuses to sleep
you know
like maybe it was just because I was
around and she wanted to spend time with
me
you know or maybe she was just depressed
you know but
when I got to do that I reported her to
the social worker again
and the social worker just told me there
was she could have drug test my kids
that's all the way now she goes because
they're minors
yeah I was like what the [__] what do
you mean like
I know there's plenty of stories where
people get to have their kids drug
tested because they've been
but it wasn't nothing about I had
nothing she was just being biased
towards me the whole time
you know and let us recommendation for
my counselors from teachers
from our neighbors and
at the end in the end after fighting for
two years I just I got nothing
so
um
I learned a lot about myself going
through that though
you know I learned how
how weak I really am
I've always thought of myself as some
big strong tough guy and I'm not
um much less than that
you know
um
I'm broken
I've been beat down
it's been the hardest part for you
losing your kids
yeah
so the process is losing my kids
I don't know what to do I'll reach out
to my mom and my mom would just
she would be happy that I was crying
telling me that that's what I get for
trying to get the babies to get away
from their mom
so I took it as like so [__] my kids
right because I was looking out for my
kid's safety all along
okay for you to tell me that means that
you don't care about my kids
so
um my mom left my dad at the age of
three
I haven't seen him since then
she reached out to me one time when I
was about 13. and I just brushed him off
because of everything my mom had put in
my hand about him
you know
so
the price of losing my kids I reached
out to him and
he really kicked it off like
I had a lot of questions for him I
remember him
and I'm also surprised they hit all the
answers to it
you know but when you explain our
relationship it was the same exact way I
explained my relationship with my
daughters
you know when it took my daughters the
kids just take them they took me
you know our souls were intertwined
so
it's like as if I'm lost
oh my dad
went as far as to live in his new his
second son after me
he thought he was never going to see us
again
and I have a little brother named Isaac
that lives out of Mexico
so
I reached out to my dad sometime in May
of 2020 of 2020
um it's so funny because I was just
looking at the messages the other day
and
I only got to know him for one year
he got killed May 21st
the first time I reached out to him was
sometime like uh May 20th somewhere
around there um
if I got so ironic just just really odd
just
because
let me see if I can pull it up right now
you know um
May 18th
was the first time
me and my dad actually started talking
you know what that was the point where I
was calling him every day
he had a lot of good advice you know if
it wasn't for him so when I first
reached out to him I wasn't getting a
little type of business from my
daughters
tcfs was really just
the [__] BTS Like I had already got
laid much without seeing my daughters
and I was supposed to get three
scheduled visits a week
and I was getting done
I had already given up you know and
when I reached out to him
he ends up telling me
to not give up like he did
just keep trying
to never give up
kids are both the most important thing
in life
you know
to not be like him
you know he regretted everything he
regretted you he
how much he regrets like not trying hard
enough
you know even though he did change his
life around
you know he had a good job
he had a couple of vacation homes
you know he was doing real good
but
you know I took his advice and I reached
out to the social worker again well it
would be lowest to me and everybody else
we had just got a new social worker
and his social worker was actually
really nice
and started scheduling my visits
it was looking like a you know like I
got a
I started getting to see my daughters
again
and everything was good
up until January of this year that's
when I lost the case
and uh they gave some custody to the mom
uh
they they they get ready little
vegetation no nothing
uh I learned that the system was really
biased
there's no type of programs for single
fathers in the whole country
uh
I couldn't even get into a drug rehab
you know I've had a major I've had a
really bad drug issue
and I was trying to get it to rehab they
could even uh offer me a program because
I wasn't court ordered the courses made
it seem as if I was
uh I was an absent parent the whole time
which I clearly wasn't you know
I clearly wasn't if I'm trying to call
everybody every single day
worried about my daughters you know day
in and day out
I went through a really bad depression
with my daughters you know what's he got
taken away from me
uh
I still haven't found myself
you know I don't and
everybody tells me I gotta move on I got
to be happy I gotta you know but I can't
I mean there's you know any good parent
would understand that
you know your kids mean the world to you
you know and
you're not gonna be yourself without
them anymore you're lying
I can't even listen to the same music
almost listen to
how about country type of guy you know
that's my favorite genre
I can't listen to that music no more
everything reminds me my daughters
so
I'm in downtown wandering the streets
just
last
what is your drug
uh fellow
I started mixing with I started smoking
fellow uh running through my dad and I
got killed
um
I just barely started doing heroin
recently it was only so I could get into
a drug rehab because since I wasn't
court-ordered I wasn't on probation or
anything
um they could just take me
and they won't take you if you're dirty
for PCP for Coke for meth for for
for any other drugs except for hair oil
and alcohol
and I had to stop drinking because of my
liver so
in order to be able to get into that
drug rehab Tarzana hopes I had to start
messing with Heroin
hello
and
in the process
in the process of messing heroin
I ended up just getting strung out just
for them to tell me that they think our
patient would be better for me you know
so I'm like what do you mean outpatient
like I'm ending up dying out here you
know
can we even show that already
and I kept looking I kept looking I
couldn't find one
and I really wanted to go see my dad
so
finally I found one
you know I'm going to the detox for the
detox
it's only for about two weeks you know
you go to detox first day you go to
rehab after that
you know but in between says they didn't
have nobody open beds I got released
was I got a detox
so at that point
I didn't have a purpose anymore
there was a point of me going back to
rehabbing just getting clean
you know
I already lost my daughters
when I talked to my mother-in-law she
just tells me I don't have a second
chance you don't get no Second Chances
in his life with your kids
so
uh
here I am doing one of the deadliest
drugs possible
no I'm already
I've known so many people to die for
this drug
and I know it's only a better time till
I had my day
you know but
it's just kind of lost our purpose and
everything
you feel like every everything and
everyone is working against you
I want to say work against me
but yeah I mean
I think the biggest disappointment was
with my daughters I expected a lot more
from DCFS
you know
I expected a lot more
I thought of them a lot better
until I went through but when I went
through with him
and so I realized that it's not even
just my kids are like I started really
thinking about everybody else's kids
like [__]
like what kind of hands are we putting
our kids in like you know
I think it used to be more transparency
in the whole DCFS and
I think he usually have like a part of
the wrecks that was really wants to keep
everything private because they're
miners but I think that should be the
reason why it's public you know
you know I think it should be the vice
versa like with the you know when you're
an adult everything is public when
you're about everything is private no it
shouldn't be like that
you know I think it should be the
opposite way around when you're a minor
it should be things should be public
when you're the dog everything should be
private because as an adult it'll really
mess up your chances getting a job you
know getting certain careers you know do
it going to certain schools doing
certain things you want to do and this
you shouldn't be you know you should
have it should be a double jeopardy type
of thing you shouldn't go to jail it's
not to pay for your [__] your crimes
on the streets when it comes to being
who you want to be you know
I said a minor everybody should be more
aware of what's going on to those kids
in those little sponsor homes that were
just in the system itself
is really foul
you know um
where are you staying now
on the streets
you're in a tent or yeah right off a 30
big
um I left my hood recently
I was under my hood but
um
it was too hard to it's too hard to get
fed over there
it's a lot easier to obtain it right
here little town
it's almost at every corner you know
so how do you make money now
oh man
um
usually filled with drugs I'll buy it
buy a good amount
and just sell enough to be able to
support myself again
you know it's a really high because
uh my intellers is pretty high right now
you know
down a Coronado stealing
but the reason why I don't do that is
because I'm kind of a burn like any type
of Market to any store last prevention
is zombie regardless you don't look at
me you're just face tattoos yeah exactly
I'll be yelling [__] watch me you
know
like
so hello hello I don't have a good
chance of stealing anything so I
plus I don't do anything to go back to
jail
you know
uh we've been hoping for housing lately
but I really need to go to rehab
you know that's what I've been
I mean I've been really old are you
still hoping you have your daughters
back in your life
yeah
but I need to go get clean first
I hope at least you know
I know that would make everything better
a whole lot better
but without any kind of type of a
little show or signs are like just kind
of like a cursed bit
I just
it was all purpose
Isaac what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
just be myself
be who I really want to be
there's no worry about what others got
to say about you
you know
because they don't matter
all right Isaac thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
all the luck in the world thank you
thanks